Star Wars game without a death star
level is like Hoth without Walker's or a
Jedi without a lightsaber fortunately EA
and dice have a death star map for star
wars battlefront in the works the Death
Star expansion is the third of four
expansion packs included in star wars
battlefront season pass the first
expansion called outer rim launches in
March and will allow players to fight
along the factories of Sullust and
battle within Jabba the Hutt's palace on
Tatooine the following expansion takes
place investment and is scheduled for a
summer release and in fall 2016 we will
get the app / mentioned Death Star
expansion the final expansion will
launch in early 2017 but we do not know
much about that one yet if you didn't
drop fifty dollars on the season pass
but you're still yearning for more
battlefront content if you're not too
free updates are on the way the January
update will hit on Wednesday and it
features two new multiplayer game modes
for Tatooine a themed costumes from the
Empire Strikes Back for Luke and Han a
space for daily challenges and the
ability to create private matches the
februari update will include a new map
on Hoth that will support the game's
larger game modes for more on Star Wars
Battlefront and all things gaming you're
already in the right place
you